hello sir hi how are you fine you very
nice to meet you thank you for talking
to us he arrived a little late at a
location we were only told about an hour
before a weekly Karl s push to mall
champion of true democracy or rebellious
criminal he was here to tell us but on
the condition we'd call him mr.
president let's start with your title if
we can you want to be referred to as
president boost tomorrow I quite
understand that but there are many in
Catalonia who don't believe yet that
you're the legitimate president of the
country just explain to me why in exile
you believe you are still the president
of Catalonia but a lot are important to
you for a very simple reason Catalan and
Spanish law says the only thing that can
remove the president is the Parliament
who elected him it's two weeks since he
unilaterally declared independence for
Catalonia he's been here in Brussels
since then not fleeing justice he
insists but seeking it at that Camino to
be treated like a criminal like a drug
trafficker like a pedophile like a
serial killer I think this is abuse this
isn't politics this is using the courts
to do politics some of the cabinet he
once led are now in jail refused bail
for their part in the illegal referendum
he's fighting extradition from Brussels
but if he thought he gets support
understanding from the European Union he
was wrong no one has come to back you up
at all will never come back it is very
disappointing to see that in a European
Union that we are all part of they can
respond to situations in Poland and
Hungary cannot respond to the situation
in Catalonia epidemic at the moment what
about the referendum itself 90% said yes
but only 40 odd percent turned up those
against independence boycotted it he
told me they'd been intimidated the
Spanish police violence on October the
1st was roundly can
but since then outside the region at
least sympathy for independence has
waned one of your justifications for
wanting independence is that you are a
persecuted people the Revengers are
persecuted Catalonians are not really
persecuted and it depends it depends is
Catalan language equal to Spanish
language no no are the Catalan
Parliament powers protected know in the
past few weeks uncertainty has prompted
well over 2000 companies to move their
HQs out of Catalonia not his fault he
said but Madrid's for bringing in laws
making it easier for them to move
hospitals economics and the la misma the
west under Catalonia the economic cost
of authoritarian actions against
Catalonia will be paid by the whole of
the EU not just Spain and Catalonia it's
not very intelligent to declare an
economic war against Catalonia just to
fight against the independence movement
are you willing to spend 30 years in
jail if that's what it comes to it's a
threat because the crime I'm accused of
could result in 30 years in prison
it's madness it's not justice it's
vengeance the election is six weeks away
he says he'll fight it from here somehow
and he'll respect the result he's not so
sure Madrid will if he wins Mark Stone
Sky News in Brussels